uh well you mentioned the prime minister
and it's not often we get to talk to
someone like you who's had so much
experience in
in number 10 and number 11. um
look what what's your view on what's
being what's being said at the moment
and the questions over the
the integrity in downing street
well as you know i prefer to talk about
access to the digital
uh services and i would like to say
something about what's happening in
india
because something could be done about
that immediately but yes look
it's pretty clear to me that three
things have got to happen if you're
going to have proper standards in public
life
you need a register of gifts so any
gifts the prime minister receives
got to be registered got to be made
public and so nobody is beholden to
anybody
else and gifts are all declared and
clearly there were gifts involved in the
refurbishment of this flag the second
thing is you need a register of
conflicts of interest
it's clear that there are downing street
officials who were in the private sector
doing other jobs while at the same time
being public officials
supposedly serving full-time in the
public sector that can't continue you
need a register of what's gone wrong
and you need to say look you're either
working for the
government and the public interest or
you're working for a private company you
can't do both here
and i think the third thing you've got
to really be
careful about is is obviously people
reporting
uh their lobbying activities i mean if
the prime minister is lobbied
for a commercial interest he's got to
report it and so there should be a
register of lobbying
that makes it absolutely clear who was
talking to whom about certain things
including
over the telephone because we cannot
have this impression growing that
some people have got access to
government and other people
don't it just seems completely unfair
there are millions of people around this
country at the moment who want to say
something
about something that's wrong they want
sorted out by the prime minister they
don't get this access
but some privileged people do one law
for an elite
one law for the rest is simply not fair
i mean during your time in number 10 and
in number 11 i mean there must have been
people that you were having contact with
people who had access
to you because they were running a huge
corporation or
or whatever it may be i mean they end up
because of that having a louder voice
don't they
well you meet people but then you report
that you've met them what seems to be
happening here is that
there's private conversations going on
on the internet or going on in
telephones and they're not properly
reported you need to register all this
in the public interest everything has
got to be seen to be above board
and no prime minister no minister should
be seen to be beholden
to someone who gives him money for this
or for that
or who's got special access for one
reason or another
that's all going to be above board
otherwise people will lose faith
and lose trust in the way the political
systems work and i fear that scandal
is going to follow this government as
long as it is in power
unless it does something to clean up its
act look should
in in your opinion and and it's great to
talk to you now that you're you're away
from all
the the big offices of state because you
think you've been
configured because you can be well look
you can be a bit more frank can't you
can be a bit more straightforward about
this with with comments that
attributed to the prime minister around
the pandemic and let the bodies pile
high let it rip i mean
it's denied that it is said but when
you're in number 10 when you're
in a meeting behind closed doors
presumably
yeah as prime minister you are much more
frank about what's going on you would
say
things would you that that you wouldn't
expect to be repeated
anywhere else yeah but this is a matter
of public policy i mean i think what
people are really asking
was that really the prime minister's
view and was he slow in uh
undertaking a lockdown because that was
what he felt so
i think he's got to clarify it this is
not just your private comments about an
individual
or about some event that has happened
this is about
public policy and i think you've got to
be honest and open with the government
if that was your view let's
let's hear that that was your view and
then you change of you but
i think there's got to be some honesty
when it comes to the saving of lives
look
look this morning you know there are a
million cases
of kobe being reported every day now
there's a hundred thousand people dying
a week in india
four hundred thousand people they
suspect uh have died
and and it's 15 months into this
pandemic and surely we can get the
equipment
the oxygen the vaccinations to all the
people in the world because nobody is
safe until
everyone's safe and these are the issues
that i think the prime minister
should be directing his attention to
today okay well just
just in 30 seconds because we're almost
off air because you've
pointed that out and it is important as
you say do you think these other issues
are
at the moment at least a distraction
i i think what we've got to talk about
is saving lives but we've got to have
good standards of government as well and
i'm interested in this morning in
getting an agreement between all the
countries
that can make sure that everybody is
safe because we do something about the
spread of the disease
the mutation forgive me forgive me for
butting in but what should what should
sakir be focusing on then
oh sakia will focus on i think getting
to the truth of what's been happening
because
we need to know what the truth is okay
gordon brown
really good to talk to you this morning
thank you very much indeed